but we begin with new allegations
against Georgia Republican Senate
nominee that's Herschel Walker less than
two weeks before election day a second
woman now says that he paid for her
abortion and even drove her to the
clinic after she initially decided not
to go through with it now he was married
at the time and the woman says they were
having an affair Walker calls the
allegations a lie he also terms that
foolishness this comes in the midst of a
very tight race that could help
determine control of the Senate Nicole
Killian is on Capitol Hill Nicole good
morning to you
Gail good morning Herschel Walker is
doubling down on this new claim saying
it's not true but the accuser insists
that this is not politically motivated
and says she has proof
I'm not going to stop this seat is too
important GOP Senate nominee Herschel
Walker hit the airwaves Wednesday night
hours after a second accuser claimed he
pressured her to get an abortion I'm
done with this foolishness that's not a
denial attorney Gloria Allred represents
the woman who she identified as Jane Doe
he encouraged me to have an abortion and
gave me the money to do so the woman
described a six-year relationship with
Walker while he was married and playing
in the NFL she says that in April 1993
she found out she was pregnant and told
Walker she couldn't go through with the
abortion he was upset and said that he
was going to go back with me to the
clinic the next day for me to have the
abortion well her lawyer did not present
receipts from the clinic she did provide
what she claimed was other evidence of
the relationship from a photo to
handwritten cards and a recorded message
purportedly from Walker
the woman said she decided it to come
forward due to Walker's anti-abortion
rights stance I believe in life and
following other allegations by another
woman that he paid for her abortion in
2009. Herschel Walker is a hypocrite
and he is not fit to be a U.S senator
what I'm saying is this is a lot and
I've said it once and I've moved on my
campaign this stuff needs to stop
you're trying to ruin people's lives on
the campaign Trail many of Walker
supporters seemed unfazed although a new
poll found Walker with a 52 percent
unfavorable rating among Georgia voters
a number that's gone up since last month
I think what he stands for is the truth
you know everybody has done bad things
in their life I mean even me and I'm I'm
pretty darn good
well that woman told us she's already
voted for Walker in fact more than a
million people have cast their ballots
in early voting in Georgia's shattering
record Walker's Democratic opponent
Senator Rafia Warnock called the latest
allegations part of a troubling pattern
Tony
yeah and then the question is do voters
believe it and how much the voters care
if they do believe it Nicole Killian
Forest once again Nicole thank you very
much